[Music]  et has some exclusive new insight into  Taylor Swift split from Calvin Harris  we've learned the 26 year old was  talking to pal's about tying the knot  with a DJ just weeks ago and our source  believes the breakup was 100% him not  her and not mutual but Taylor seemed  fine over the weekend crashing a fan's  New Jersey wedding on Saturday and  performing blank space meanwhile Calvin  was DJing in Las Vegas and they appear  to still be on good terms on Thursday  Taylor retweeted Calvin's tweet the only  truth here is that a relationship came  to an end and what remains is a huge  amount of love and respect still the  split seems shocking to Psalm since  there weren't many signs of trouble the  duo celebrated their one-year  anniversary in March with a romantic  getaway and Taylor's friends were fans  of the DJ we got one year cake that's  one yeah he's great honestly he's such a  wonderful guy  [Music]  you